now what I'm gonna do is as you go ahead
and work that out I'm actually going to
show you a neat thing in desmos desmos
is great for graphing functions
obviously but fun fact most of you
probably don't realize it also evaluates
integrals so I'll ask you to go ahead do
the working for that but just because
I'm lying the time I'm going to show you
how to use decimals to confirm your
working and that might be helpful to you
in the future so let's pull this up here
now let's let's deal with the first one
first so I'm doing this integral
underneath the parabola and what you
need to do is on the desmos keyboard
over in the bottom right hand corner you
can see it says functions and you might
have started over here intrigue or stats
you've got all these other ones the one
we want is misc for miscellaneous and
then down there in the bottom left hand
corner I wonder if you've spotted that
curly looking s that's the integral
symbol so it's expecting us to put in a
lower boundary and an upper boundary and
then it will be very very polite and
evaluate for us so you're going to get
negative two click carefully up into
that top boundary two negative one and a
bit of a tip for you here make sure you
put your whatever you're integrating put
it into brackets so it integrates the
entire thing which in this case is 2x
squared plus 8x plus 8 I'm gonna close
my bracket and then in order to get that
DX you've got to change keyboards I did
that really quickly in the bottom left
hand corner of desmos you can see it
says ABC so that can change your
keyboard to an alphabetical keyboard and
we of course are integrating with
respect to X and you get a value which I
hope when you do this as you actually do
the integral will confirm for you it's
actually 2/3 so max I did do that
quickly let me confirm for you again on
the normal desmos keyboard if you don't
see the desmos keyboard by the way
you're going to need to press there's a
little keyboard icon in the bottom
right-hand corner press that this
keyboard will appear to click on
functions which is over there near the
top right of the keyboard and then the
integral sign is in the bottom left of
this little grid of buttons that's just
appeared so hopefully you can see it
right there
so there's the integral for a-1 it does
give us a value of 2 over 3 and just to
really emphasize or anyone who didn't
miss it
or who did miss it rather I'm not saying
you can just put this into DES awesome
tell her I've got an answer you're gonna
have to do this by hand but this is a
nice way to confirm that you did get the
right answer you're gonna get two thirds
there and then when you go over to the
other integral over here I'm gonna put
this on a whole new line so just to do
this yes I know parent if you've got it
you've got an actual keyboard I'm
tapping this on my iPad but if you've
got an actual keyboard there's a bunch
of keyboard shortcuts that desmos has
like you can type in s QR t for square
root and if you type in int you will get
an integral like this
let's get 82 which is the integral
underneath the cubic so that's from
negative 1 all the way up to 1 pop in
your brackets there close your brackets
and then go with respect to X and you
get a very nice neat value of 2 okay yes
we do wish you could take those listen
to the exam that will be handy but
unfortunately not sorry about that so
therefore and just to re-emphasize it if
you go and look in the notes that we're
uploading onto every section every
session in online learning you'll see my
full working here where I've done the
integral by hand you will end up with
two thirds and with two so I would
combine that by saying that the total
area let's get rid of desmos now we
don't need it the total area is equal to
2/3 plus 2 which is 2 and 2/3 units
squared
. okay so we'd like you to go from here
just to end out the lesson because we do
have more to have a go out I'm sorry I
took so long I was could we sort of
started and stopped at a finite graph
also slowed you down a fair bit question
is 3 & 4 which is not much to be honest
you could actually honestly do it in
like the next 20 30 minute these are the
questions we'd like you to tackle for
homework in in the lead-up to tomorrow's
lesson we're gonna go further into
compound regions but the cover the
skills we've covered today of looking at
a volume sorry not a volume an area very
carefully and dividing up into the
appropriate sections that's that's what
you have so
yes you're welcome max your um your your
I've been you know trying to look out
for you a little bit but I make no
apology so I'm giving you tomorrow okay
so I hope that makes sense I'll pause
there if they don't wants to hang around
with some questions on the basis of
those two examples that we gave or from
questions three and four in the exercise
then please go ahead but otherwise for
now exercise 1f have a go at them good
luck and we'll see you in tomorrow's
lessoned thanks again for working hard I
know the graphs are a lot of effort it's
calling back a lot of knowledge from a
while back but I hope for always useful
and stick around if you have any
questions then you want me to do it
longhand would you like to see the
actual area the integral I should say
okay so we know where we're going to end
up let me help you out with actually
doing the evaluation okay so for
starters we're going to go for the
primitive function right so we're going
to increase all that indices and then
divide through so it looks to me like
I'm going to get 2x cubed on three
actually you know what I'm just going to
pause there then since I'm right at the
start I should have done this right at
the beginning you might have noticed one
of the tricks I used when I was graphing
was I did some factorization right that
was really helpful yeah so I'm gonna do
the same thing here and that will make
things even easier for us and part of
things part of what makes this difficult
is that you have a lot of substitution
to do every single term that you've got
you have to do a substitution into your
calculate in fact II have to do two
because you've got the lower bound and
the upper bound it's questions three and
four in exercise 1f Sasha hopefully that
helps so what I'm gonna do here is I'm a
decent factorization that will really
help me out
in terms of making this much simpler to
deal with so first thing I'm going to
take out a factor of two so this
negative 2 to negative 1 is still there
leaves me with this this was the same
thing that I had from earlier which i
factorized in order to find its
x-intercepts right so I'm going to do
that trick again because then I can use
another piece of knowledge that I'm
aware of and I wonder if you've pieced
it together yet x squared plus 4x plus 4
this is X plus 2 or squared now
if this was the question I handed you I
hope your brain is going huh no no and I
can do something with this I don't have
to expand I mean I can I can still
integrate but it's just gonna take
longer yeah and even when you have a
calculator helper you just got a lot of
substitution to do I can use reverse
chain rule here yeah does that help so
that will not only make this easier to
do it's just a less error-prone method
okay so trap for young players in fact
when I did this question myself I
designed this question because I'm sort
of was a bit sick of the textbook
examples and I just went through in my
own work you know I was like yeah I'm
just gonna do it all turn by turn like I
myself in factorized five minutes
earlier and I forgot to do it when I was
integrating so something which you get
better with with experience so I'm going
to do the reverse chain rule now so I
have a look this is a really nice
example because the inside derivative
happens to be one so I kind of don't
need to worry about it I increase the
index and then I divide through by the
index like so okay so now I'm going from
negative 2 to negative 1
I can factorize again the way I did the
two at the front I can take that divided
by 3 at the front as well so that goes
2/3 that's X plus 2 cubed negative 2
negative 1 what have I got here
well the 2/3 comes out the front and
then I have some really nice easy things
to evaluate it right so I'm gonna have
negative 1 plus 2 that's my top boundary
so that gives me negative 1 plus 2 is
just 1 there's my upper boundary
evaluated I subtract the lower boundary
but then I've got negative 2 plus 2
which is 0 cubed look at that it's
almost like I planned this right so this
is going to be 2/3 x one take away 0
which is just 1 and this is the answer
that we saw before so I guess if you
wanted you know if I had gone back to
this step right up here let's just
suppose I didn't do any of that
simplification didn't use your vest
channel what is this good thing going to
look like well I'm going to be
integrating this is what I started doing
before I stopped myself 2 X cubed on 3 +
8 x squared on 4 will be 4x squared + 8
X and then I'm going to be doing that
from negative 2
- - negative one which I'm very
confident will give me exactly the same
answer
it's just that I'm gonna have to
evaluate so many more things and it's
going to take me a whole lot of time
like even just to write it is going to
take me forever I'm just going to go
just for the sake of illustration ^ 2
times that because negative 1 cubed plus
4 lots of 1 I'm even doing some
shortcuts in my head I'm gonna take away
let's say okay so now I'm doing negative
2 - lots of negative 8 on 3 + 4 lots of
negative 2 squared is 4 plus 8 lots of
negative - oh wow I'm just I'm getting a
headache just looking at that thing okay
it'll give you the right answer but it's
where it pays to think before you move
forward and it'll save you a lot of time
and effort and also be less error-prone
like I mentioned before are you happy
with that been